[Musique]
et ses invités aujourd'hui et on est
très content c'est vous c'est stéphane
dion et régis jantes et bonjour à tous
les deux bonjour et bienvenue vos noms
sont familiers ici bien sûr à la
rédaction de france 24 stéphane vous
êtes le correspondant de rfi et de
libération à kiev régis vous êtes
correspondant à tbilissi en géorgie
spécialiste des anciennes républiques
soviétiques pour rfi et pour nous ici à
france 24 et vous co signé à quatre
mains une biographie passionnante du
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
qui s'appelle on voit à l'antenne dans
la tête d'un héros qui vient de sortir
ou qui sort tout juste aujourd'hui voilà
chez robert laffont un livre qui nous
permet de mieux connaître un ancien
comique devenu malgré lui un chef de
guerre depuis près de trois mois livre
qui a été écrit au coeur de la guerre on
en parlera bien sûr aussi de cette
guerre pour commencer je trie qu'on
regarde ou qu'on écoute plutôt volodymyr
et d'un ski c'était mardi au milieu de
la cérémonie d'ouverture du festival de
cannes
nous avons besoin d'un nouveau chaplin
qui prouvera une fois de plus que le
cinéma n'est pas muet bien sûr nous
continuerons à nous battre car nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix que de nous
battre pour la liberté je suis convaincu
que le dictateur perdra
c'était un discours surprise que celui
de vladimir et n'inscrit trophée truffé
de références au cinéma dont le
dictateur de charlie chaplin on vient
d'entendre ou encore apocalypse now il
est intéressant cet extrait parce qu'il
dit beaucoup de ce président ukrainien
que le grand public a découvert fin
février dernier peut-être d'abord de son
lien avec la comédie avec le cinéma
allait il fait la grande boucle en fait
parce que c'est un comédien c'est un
acteur à l'origine alors je pense que
les cinéphiles ukrainien on était très
étonné de voir volodymyr zelensky au
festival de cannes parce que le dernier
film qu'il a réalisé en 2010 8 juste
avant de devenir président c'est pas
c'est pas un chef-d'oeuvre faut bien le
dire
c'est pas de l'agglo grande qualité
c'est un homme qui a fait surtout des
séries qui a fait des shows d'humour qui
fait de l'animation et je pense que de
se retrouver projeté dans la cérémonie
d'ouverture de cannes même pour vladimir
zelensky ça doit être assez vertigineux
autre chose on l'a vu partout à vladimir
de lens qui ces derniers mois on l'a vu
dans tous les parlements ici en france
aux états unis on a vu à l'assemblée
générale de l'onu ici à cannes je crois
qu'il va faire aussi l'ouverture de de
davos avec des discours incroyablement
écrit qu'est ce que c'est lui qui les
écrit est ce qu on le sait d'ailleurs
quelqu'un écrit pour lui effectivement
mais apparemment c'est quand même lui
qui donne l'impulsion à chaque fois et
et qui donne le temps de ce qu'il veut
ce qu'il veut raconter quoi
alésia isi n'ont effectivement il est il
est celle adressée à chaque audience un
discours approprié donner la bonne
référence historique ce qui est pas
toujours absolument le cas mais ça c'est
effectivement important aussi parce que
et c'est vrai pas seulement de lucrèce
est vrai tous les pays qui se bat contre
l'impérialisme russe se disent on la
géorgie etc d'où un besoin absolu de se
battre sur tous les plants pour ne pas
être oublié parce que pour beaucoup de
pays des grands pays du monde et bien la
russie compte plus que ces pays donc
c'est aussi pourquoi il ya cette
communication qui est parfois un peu mal
comprises mais voilà la raison ça dit
beaucoup de la bête de communication qui
laissa c'est ça c'est très présent dans
son parcours il a un conseiller
qui parle quand c'est à la communication
c'est un chef adjoint de
l'administration présidentielle qui a
trente trois 33 ans qui s'appelle youri
kostyuk et qui écrit et co écrit avec
l'huile et les ces fameux discours ces
fameuses pastilles vidéo et ce conseil
du ricoh stock n'est autre que le
scénariste de la série serviteur du
peuple qui a amené vous le dit mr dsk au
pouvoir ce qu'a dit aussi cette séquence
et qui est intéressante il a été acclamé
standing ovation à cannes l'a dit fille
la situation n'est pas la même en
ukraine et dans le reste et en occident
il est devenu un héros un héros dans le
reste de l'occident en ukraine vous
raconter que c'est bon c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose oui alors standing
ovation partout où il passe dans le
monde entier mais je crois que volodymyr
zelensky frappe par sa capacité à
apporter des messages très simple sur
une situation qui est complexe il a le
don pour mettre les occidentaux les
européens devant leurs responsabilités
également devant
les problèmes moraux qui ceux qui se
posent au continent européen à l'heure
actuelle à l'heure de la guerre
maintenant en ukraine c'est un tout
petit peu différent c'est à dire que sa
popularité a fortement augmenté depuis
le 24 février
elle était en forte baisse l'année
dernière avant avant la guerre et
notamment parce qu'il y avait de gros
doute dans l'opinion publique sur sa
capacité justement à endosser ce rôle de
commandant en chef des armées en cas de
conflit avec avec la russie maintenant
après cette fameuse vidéo deux jours
après le début de la guerre on le voit
sortir dans la rue devant la présidence
ukrainienne à kiev avec ses conseillers
sa popularité a augmenté de telle façon
que c'est à peu près 90% des ukrainiens
qui ont confiance en son action il n'a
pas quitté la capitale quasiment sauf
pour aller une fois à bout de chat il me
semble depuis le début de la guerre est
ce qu'on sait alors j'imagine non mais
où ils se trouvent physiquement et à
quoi ressemblent ces journées
on le voit presque toujours
essentiellement au sein de la banque
kovac le siège de la présidence
ukrainienne autant je sache il n'y ait
pas effectivement tout le temps
notamment au départ puisqu'il y avait
des véritable menace sur son existence
donc là il était dans d'autres endroits
tenu tenu secret effectivement cette
vidéo est importante parce que font font
font revoir le contexte qui a autour
cirque elle et des commandos qui sont au
coeur de la ville des commodos russe
sait aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient mission
de le de l'assassiner c'est vrai et on a
aussi un aéroport militaire qui sauve
tout prêts tout près de kiev et où la
61e 76e divisions aéroportées russes qui
est une des plus performantes celle-ci
vraiment
l'épouvantail on pourrait dire qu'il
était en train de prendre c'était encore
précisément pour pouvoir ensuite
investir kiev et ait renversé le pouvoir
à celui qui a même des informations
maintenant selon lesquelles volodymyr
zelensky en dehors de tout protocole est
sorti de la présidence dans les
premières semaines du conflit il s'est
notamment rendu à la limite de la ville
au nord-ouest dans cette zone qui jouxte
ir pinet et butch à il l'a fait sans
prévenir la presse et aussi pour ne pas
prévenir les forces russes il était là
il paraît que ses conseillers en tous
cas la garde était extrêmement nerveuse
et il a même donné une interview à des
journalistes ukrainiens selon
laquelle dans laquelle il relate avoir
fait un déjeuner dans une zone proche de
la ligne de front il a où il a mangé du
boeuf avec des passants qui est qu'ils
étaient là donc il a quand même fait
quelques quelques sorties mais bien
entendu dans un contexte de sécurité qui
était très complexe à gérer pour lui
ouais ce qui a valu d'ailleurs une
phrase qui va rester célèbre après la
proposition américaine de le de
l'évacuer j'ai besoin de munitions et et
pas d'une évacuation ses fans je crois
qu'il avait rencontré plusieurs fois
vous le dis mears et l'ins qui vous
habite à kiev où on le rappelle la alors
peut-être c'était avant la guerre mais
la première impression qu'on a quand on
se rend compte c'est quoi alors c'est un
homme qui a changé du tout au tout en
trois ans c'est dire que le mât mois et
en trois mois encore plus je me souviens
d'une excellente consoeur ukrainienne
journaliste politique et qui me dit que
en quelques semaines de guerre volodymyr
hélène ce qui a sans doute beaucoup plus
progressé en tant que chef d'état quand
trois ans de présidence et c'est
également un constat que je partage
la dernière interview en petit comité
que je fais avec lui c'est en août de
l'année dernière au moment dé des 30 ans
de l'indépendance et ce n'est déjà plus
le même 1 par rapport à la première
rencontre de mars 2019 à l'époque c'est
quelqu'un qui souhaitait à tout prix
éviter les journalistes alors du coup il
avait organisé un déjeuner avec six
journalistes étrangers
à nos dans l'intimité c'est très
complexe alors surtout tout début de son
de son aventure politique c'est
quelqu'un qui ne maîtrisaient pas les
dossiers économiques qui ne maîtrisaient
pas les clés les gros dossiers
internationaux qui lançait de grandes
idées comme je veux offrir la paix à mes
concitoyens et lorsqu'on lui demande
comment vous allez vous y prendre il est
incapable de le dire mais surtout en
fait il se crispe il s'énerve il fait
appel à ses conseillers c'est comme si
la politique était un jeu au départ et
puis en fait il se rend compte que face
à la réalité c'est plus un jeu du tout
quoi et donc c'était assez complexe mais
maintenant c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
énormément c'est quelqu'un qui s'est pas
un intello au sens propre du terme mais
c'est quelqu'un qui sait se hisser à la
hauteur des enjeux par la force de son
travail et tous les gens qui entourent
volodymyr zelensky depuis des années
disent que c'est une véritable brut de
travail il apprend très vite je pense
qu'il sait se rendre compte de ses
erreurs également est véritablement il a
beaucoup progressé
raconter de choses qui les lie les deux
langues maternelles russe c'est qu'il a
eu du mal au début à part les ukrainiens
enfin qu'il a fait encore qu'elle y
faisait encore quelques erreurs au début
de sa présidence d'une part et d'autre
part ils avaient une aversion pour la
violence à la guerre dans lequel il
s'est retrouvé malgré lui plongé alors
il est né dans la fin des années 70 dans
une bonne famille soviétique du sud de
l'est de l'ukraine ecrivez-vous dans un
bassin métallurgique il va monter une
troupe avec ses copains on va en parler
qui va finir par le rendre célèbre et
vous écrivez qu'il est le symbole de la
bascule ukrainienne pourquoi oui
effectivement si quelqu'un qui a 13 ans
ça veut dire que tous les codes tout ou
lâches actes soviétique est quelque
chose qui lui échappe plus tôt et qui
s'est donc fait en quelque sorte après
cela en tant que citoyen en tant que que
personnalité et effectivement il était à
la fois il vient d'une région
russophone d'un bassin minier quitter
véritablement un symbole de ce que
pouvait être la classe ouvrière
soviétique et c'est donc ils avaient
tous pourra devenir un homme du monde
russes duroux schiemer comme comme
monsieur poutine adore le dire
d'ailleurs les productions de son studio
cortal 95 vendait le marché son marché
est essentiellement en russie si vous
voulez et effectivement parce qu'il est
jeune parce que la société ukrainienne
est en train de basculer on le voit deux
pics ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
ça une histoire effectivement dans ce
fait 30 ans que l'ukraine est en train
de s'émanciper de la russie avec toute
la violence ou la brutalité qu'on sait
mais il est l'homme de cette situation
parce que parce qu'il accompagne cette
société il leur fait partie il ya une
quarantaine d'années aujourd'hui la
fille de sir le nationalisme ukrainien
oui la vérité une bascule générationnel
et pour moi c'est la clef de lecture
principale de volodymyr zelensky de sa
présidence mais également de la guerre
qu'on voit actuellement on a souvent eu
des clés d'analysé comme quoi il ya un
conflit en ukraine entre l'est et
l'ouest entre les russophones et les
ukrainophones moi ça fait huit ans que
j'habite à kiev lors et je vois pas de
conflit majeur là dedans moi je parle le
russe au quotidien à kiev comprend un
petit peu l'ukrainien ça n'a jamais posé
problème
le véritable conflit il est entre les
jeunes et les personnes plus âgées entre
ceux qui ont connu l'expérience sociale
d'être des citoyens de l'union
soviétique et ceux qui ne l'ont jamais
connu et volodymyr zelensky c'est
l'homme d'une nouvelle génération la
génération des gens qui ont entre 25 et
45 ans c'est la génération des personnes
nées dans les années 1980 qui arrivent à
l'âge des responsabilités actuellement
et ces personnes n'ont absolument aucun
référentiel soviétique et du coup le
projet politique qui est proposée par la
russie ne leur parle absolument pas et
volodymyr zelensky qui à l'origine n'est
pas forcément un patriote de culture et
à la manière d'un caméléon il a dû en
fait prendre sur lui les couleurs de
cette nouvelle ukraine jeune moderne qui
est tourner plutôt vers l'europe vers la
pologne la république tchèque que vers
moscou et ça a été une évolution
naturelle pour lui je pense vous le
rappeler malheureusement le temps presse
donc
on va on va faire vite il a déjà été
président deux fois en 2015 dans une
série qui s'appelle serviteur du peuple
il était donc très connu et en ukraine
et en russie d'ailleurs pour cette série
notamment qui vous dit vous aurez
peut-être la raison pour laquelle il
s'est finalement présenté en 2019 oui
effectivement on n'a pas absolument la
clé de ce qui s'est passé mais
effectivement il travaille sur une
chaîne de télévision qui appartient à un
oligarque qui à l'époque étaient en
compétition contre un autre les gars qui
était le président de l'ukraine à
l'époque chez porsche n co et l'autre
les gars que le propriétaire de la
chaîne c'est igor colonne morris qui est
effectivement c'est lui qui va
promouvoir la boxe et ce n es
probablement que l'intention en tout cas
de l'oligarque peut-être pas de zelensky
là c'est pas tout à fait clair mais est
effectivement de de faire tomber
porochenko mais apparemment une partie
de l'histoire c'est aussi qu'ils vont se
rendre compte au cours de diffusion de
cette série télévisée qui dure sur trois
saisons et bien que c'est à la
population adhère que ça répond à leurs
besoins on raconte par exemple le 14e
épisode qui traite de la corruption et
des routes qui sont en très mauvais état
et les routes les voitures les
sensations des questions très
importantes partout dans le monde et est
danseuse hélène ski et son équipe ont su
capter ça donc c'est aussi que des gens
qui savent comprendre leur société en
deux mots parce que vraiment le temps
nous manque le zélote skins écrivez vous
êtes un populisme bon enfant à
l'ukrainienne vous avez wave tout à fait
alors on pourrait en parler pendant des
heures mais je crois que le le mouvement
serviteur du peuple que vaut le 10 mars
lines qui a développé et à ses proches
quelque part de la république en marche
de emmanuel macron c'est une forme de
populisme soft ou un moment donné les
idées sont moins importantes que la
manière dont on les présente et un
moment donné on n'est plus dans une
proposition politique avec des idées un
corpus idéologique mais plutôt on essaie
de d'emmener les idées de l'électorat
vers la politique et on se sent ce oui
et c'est un mouvement qui est
démocratique populiste attrape tout je
crois qu'en fait l'ukraine est beaucoup
plus moderne que ce qu'on veut bien
croire et qu'elle est parfois même en
avance sur les tendances politiques de
notre siècle lundi fidélité indéfectible
au chef mais aussi capacité fantastique
à brasser du vent voilà ce qu'est le
zoloft qu'ils mènent pour vous merci
beaucoup il y a beaucoup de choses dans
ce livre écrit dans 20 ans record bravo
à vous donner dans quel contexte donc
chez robert laffont dans la tête d'un
héros merci beaucoup à vous deux et
alors c'est bientôt on se retrouve très
vite sur l'antenne de france 24